.
* Ein Hahn kräht,
eine Ziege meckert *
Schon als Kind haben sie davon
geträumt, Tierärztinnen zu werden.
Nach fünfjährigem Studium starten sie
mit viel Elan ins Berufsleben.
Aber dann folgt der Alltag,
der nebst viel Freude,
auch viele Schwierigkeiten
und Überraschungen mit sich bringt.
Er freut sich genauso fest wie Sie.
Wir haben drei junge Tierärztinnen
begleitet:
Alix spezialisiert sich derzeit
auf der Notfallstation
des Tierspitals in Bern
auf die Spitzentechnologie.
Zusammen mit ihrem Team
betreut sie alle kritischen Notfälle.
Im Kanton Waadt steht Florence
zwischen Rindern und Pferden
im Broye-Gebiet.
Obwohl die Bauern
unter grossem Druck stehen,
behält Florence
ihre Ruhe und ihre gute Laune.
Nach ihrer Zeit
mit Kühen und Schafen im Jura
spezialisiert sich Eléonore
in Estavayer-le-Lac auf Kleintiere.
Sie hat hier
auch viel mit Besitzern zu tun,
die sehr an ihren Tieren hängen.
Und das sind sie:
unsere jungen Tierärztinnen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Das Tierspital in Bern
hat gerade erst geöffnet.
Aber das Wartezimmer ist schon
voll mit verängstigten Patienten,
die brav warten,
bis sie an der Reihe sind.
Heute ist Alix
für die Notfälle zuständig.
Sie freut sich über jeden Patienten,
auch wenn jeder Fall anders ist
und jedes Tier
seinen eigenen Charakter hat.
Der kleine Hund
ist sehr, sehr gestresst.
Trotz Stress behandelt sie
jedes Tier wie einen Einzelfall.
Das hast du super gemacht.
Es bleibt keine Zeit zum Durchatmen -
schon ist der nächste Notfall da:
eine junge Katze, die wie ein
Häufchen Elend in ihrem Käfig hockt.
Yuzu ist eine Katze,
die vor 2 Std. von zwei Hunden
heftig gebissen wurde.
Sie hat eine Wirbelfraktur
und Verletzungen am Bauch.
Besitzerin Laurence und Yuzu
stehen noch unter Schock.
Zwei Hunde kamen angerannt ...
Und sie verstand nicht,
wie ihr geschah?
Sie wurde an einen Zaun gedrückt
und hatte keine Chance zu fliehen.
Okay.
Ich vernahm einen Riesenlärm.
Hunde bellten
und verfolgten ein anderes Tier.
Plötzlich merkte ich,
dass es sich um meine Katze handelt.
Laurence wollte ihre Katze
so verzweifelt retten,
dass sie ganz alleine
auf die Hunde losgerannt ist.
Ich schrie wie verrückt und ...
Dann liessen sie von ihr ab?
Ich glaube,
sie erschraken in diesem Moment.
Sie liessen von ihr ab,
und sie flüchtete auf einen Baum.
Hätte ich nicht eingegriffen,
hätten sie sie totgebissen.
Sie wäre jetzt garantiert tot.
Ja, Schätzchen.
So ist es.
Wir kümmern uns um sie.
- Ich mache mir keine Sorgen.
Der erste Tierarzt sagte Laurence,
sie müsse zwischen Einschläfern
und einer teuren Behandlung wählen.
Natürlich gibt sie ihre Katze
nicht so schnell auf.
Kaum nimmt sie Notiz von uns,
beginnt sie zu schnurren.
Sie leckt uns immer ab.
Sie gehört einfach zur Familie.
Alix untersucht Yuzus Narbe.
Der Tierarzt von Aigle hat den Bauch
über die gesamte Länge zugenäht.
Am meisten Sorgen
bereitet Alix der Wirbelbruch.
Ein falsche Bewegung,
und Yuzu könnte gelähmt sein.
Wir müssen sie röntgen.
Da sie einen Wirbelbruch hat,
sollten wir sie
möglichst wenig bewegen,
damit das Rückenmark
nicht noch mehr beschädigt wird.
Deshalb versuchen wir,
sie so stabil wie möglich zu halten.
Nach verschiedenen Untersuchungen
realisiert Alix,
wie ernst der Fall ist.
Sie bespricht das weitere Vorgehen
mit Katja,
der leitenden Notfallärztin.
Er hat hier
eine abnormale Rückenposition
und kann nicht gut gehen.
Der Rücken ist sehr stark gekrümmt.
Man sieht einen richtigen Knick
in der Wirbelsäule.
Links hat sie auch Motorikprobleme.
- Ein bisschen, ja.
Sogar Katja hat Zweifel.
Sie wirkt stabil.
Aber ob sie jemals wieder ein
normales Katzenleben führen kann,
können wir noch nicht sagen.
Sie hat Pipi gemacht.
- Das ist gut. Pipi machen ist gut.
Das ist tatsächlich
ein gutes Zeichen.
Es bedeutet, dass das Rückenmark
nicht durchtrennt ist.
Yuzu wird vorsichtig
in ihren Käfig gesetzt,
und Alix ruft den Tierarzt an,
der die Bisswunde am Bauch
genäht hat.
Der Tierarzt hat geschlossen, Katja.
Er hat heute geschlossen.
Er ist nicht da?
- Alles zu, ja.
Alix muss eine Diagnose stellen,
ohne zu wissen,
was schon gemacht wurde.
Sie will den Fall mit
verschiedenen Spezialisten anschauen.
Zuerst geht sie zum Neurologen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Stell ihn weg, stell ihn weg!
Yuzu kann ihre Pfoten absetzen.
Es sieht aus,
als ob sie noch alle Reflexe hätte.
Das ist schon fast wie ein Wunder.
Das ist sehr, sehr positiv.
Sie hat noch Gefühl in den Pfoten.
Sie kann sie sogar anheben
und richtig absetzen:
Das Hirn
kontrolliert ihre Bewegungen.
Die Verbindung zwischen Hirn und
Pfoten ist nicht ganz unterbrochen.
Mit dieser guten Nachricht
geht Alix sofort
zu den Radiologen und Chirurgen.
Sie bewegt sich ein bisschen,
aber nicht komplett, nur wenig.
Sie hat keine grossen Schmerzen,
setzt Urin ab
und kann den Schwanz bewegen.
Das ist erstaunlich.
Sogar die Spezialistinnen
sind erstaunt.
Die Wirbelsäule ist stark deformiert.
Das Rückenmark
müsste total beschädigt sein.
Aber Yuzu zeigt immer noch Reflexe.
Das müssen wir machen, ja.
Das ist
eine sehr interessante Verletzung.
Die Chirurgin ist unsicher,
wie man vorgehen soll.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob eine Operation zur Stabilisierung
notwendig ist.
Ich würde sagen,
wir versuchen es ohne Chirurgie.
Ich würde die Katze
in der Box lassen.
Strikte Ruhe und keine Operation.
Die Wirbelsäule ist sehr verletzlich.
Die Ärzte wollen nichts riskieren.
Manchmal geht ein Tier
vor der OP besser als danach,
denn mit dem chirurgischen Eingriff
kann eine Entzündung oder ein Ödem
ausgelöst werden.
Vielleicht erholt sich die Katze,
vielleicht treten dabei
Schwierigkeiten auf.
Wenn es nicht unbedingt nötig ist,
operiert man nicht.
Bei den Untersuchungen hat sich die
Wunde geöffnet und blutet ein wenig.
Ich machen nur das Nötigste,
damit sich die Wunde
nicht noch mehr öffnet.
Ein kleine Klammer -
und schon ist es vorbei.
* Schmerzenslaut *
Schon vorbei.
Jetzt lasse ich dich in Ruhe.
Und noch ein wenig streicheln.
Ich liebe Katzen - diese
ist noch jung und wirklich süss.
Man merkt,
dass sie eingeschüchtert ist.
In solchen Fällen
muss man mehr aufpassen als sonst,
damit sie kein Trauma erleidet.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Jetzt lasse ich dich in Ruhe
und bringe dich in deine Box.
Endlich kommt Yuzu zur Ruhe.
Ob sie trotz des verletzten Wirbels
je wieder gehen kann,
wird sich erst
in ein paar Tagen herausstellen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Auch in der Tierpraxis
in Estavayer-le-Lac
bereitet man sich
auf einen neuen Arbeitstag vor.
Noch vor dem Kaffee
muss Eléonore verarztet werden.
Sie hat sich bei einer Enthornung
mit dem Brennstab am Arm verbrannt.
Jetzt möchte sie wissen,
was ihre Kollegen dazu meinen.
* Leichte Musik *
* Lachen *
Wow!
- Oh nein.
Wie ist das passiert?
Beim Enthornen mit dem Brennstab.
Jetzt müssen wir dich
in der Praxis auch noch verarzten.
Sie sind bester Laune.
Das Morgentreffen mit Kaffee ist
ein kleines Ritual in dieser Praxis.
Der Reihe nach berichten alle
über ihre Patienten.
Olivier, der Besitzer der Praxis,
hört genau zu.
Ich war bei Alain Gross
wegen einer hinkenden Charolais-Kuh.
Es passierte auf der Alp,
wo sie auch behandelt wurde.
Bei diesen schweren Rindern
gibt es oft Verstauchungen,
wenn sie mit ihren 1'000 kg
in ein Maulwurfsloch treten.
Der Austausch ist sehr wertvoll
für unsere Veterinärin.
Nach der Kaffeepause
machen sich alle an die Arbeit.
Und schon klingelt das Telefon.
Ja, hallo? Grüezi.
Eléonore macht sich auf
zu einem Notfall
in Frasses im Kanton Freiburg.
* Leichte Musik *
Sie kommt auf einen Betrieb
mit grossen Feldern
mit Hühnern und fünf Eseln,
die der Besitzer aus reiner Freude
an diesen Tieren hält.
Ciao.
Ja, ja.
Ich erbte die Leidenschaft
von meinen Eltern.
Als wir noch Kinder waren,
kauften sie ein Eselpaar.
Wir konnten die Esel reiten
oder vor den Wagen spannen.
Fast jeden Sonntag
verbrachten wir draussen mit ihnen.
Seit heute Morgen
steht Romana nicht mehr auf.
und ist voller Verletzungen.
Ich brachte ihnen heute Morgen
wie jeden Morgen etwas zu fressen.
Als ich kam, lag Romana am Boden,
ein wenig entfernt von den anderen,
und wälzte sich hin und her.
Das macht sie normalerweise nicht.
- Können Sie mir das kurz erklären?
Seit gestern ist sie ständig
in der Mitte des Parks.
Sie ist ziemlich alt -
Jahrgang 1993.
Dann ist sie zwei Jahre jünger
als ich, also 25.
Sie ist stets an einem anderen Ort.
Am Morgen lag sie hier,
dann dort und schliesslich ...
Ich machte mir Sorgen,
weil Esel eigentlich nie krank sind.
Aber wenn sie dann mal was haben,
ist es meistens sehr ernst.
Salut, Miss.
Daniel zeigt Eléonore
die Wunde am Kopf.
Er glaubt, dass Romana von ihren
Artgenossen angegriffen worden ist.
Kannst du Bianca
ein wenig wegführen?
Es ist besser, wenn die anderen Esel
nicht zu nahe kommen.
* Angespannte Musik *
Als ich kam, wälzte sich
der Esel am Boden, schlug aus.
Sie hat offensichtlich
unbeschreibliche Schmerzen.
Sie steht auf,
schmeisst sich gleich wieder hin,
wälzt sich hin und her, als ob sie
eine erträgliche Position sucht.
Hat sie gestern gefressen?
- Gestern, ja. Trockenes Brot ...
Wenn sich Esel oder Pferde
am Boden wälzen,
haben sie meist
heftige Bauchschmerzen.
In solchen Fällen
muss man die Peristaltik abhören,
die Tätigkeit des Verdauungssystems.
Bei Einhufern sind das vier Punkte.
Bei einem Punkt
hörte ich gar nichts,
das ist kein gutes Zeichen.
Wenn man nichts hört,
ist das Verdauungssystem blockiert.
Sie ist etwas mager, hat abgenommen.
Aber sie ist ja schon 25.
- Ja, das stimmt.
Mit Romana verbindet Daniel
sehr viele Erinnerungen.
Schon als ich ein Kind war,
war Romana bei uns.
Sie war immer charakterstark,
sehr beweglich und vif.
Wollte man
an den Hufen etwas machen,
musste man stets aufpassen.
Wir sagten immer,
sie habe Gummibeine,
weil sie sich manchmal
so unvorhersehbar bewegte.
Achtung,
ich würde gerne Fieber messen.
Sie ist zwar 25,
hat aber immer noch Gummibeine.
Au!
Du bist aber noch ziemlich stark,
Oma.
Der Besitzer warnte mich,
dass sie so aktiv sein könnte.
Voll eins ans Schienbein -
das passiert häufig.
Das war noch ertragbar,
denn diese Esel wiegen max. 150 kg.
Wenn aber ein 600 kg schweres Pferd
eine Kolik hat,
sollte man nicht zu nahe sein.
Achtung!
Ist gut.
Nach diesen Untersuchungen
kann ich noch nicht viel sagen.
Ich gebe ihr
schon mal ein Medikament,
um zu schauen,
ob es ihr dann besser geht.
Und ich nehme eine Blutprobe.
In diesem Alter funktioniert einiges
nicht mehr so gut,
das Herz, die Nieren, die Leber.
Mich interessierte v.a. die Leber.
Soll man das Tier sofort
von seinen Schmerzen befreien
oder hat man noch Zeit
für eine Diagnose
und einen späteren Eingriff?
* Handy *
Eléonore nimmt Blut ab
und verabreicht ein Mittel
gegen Bauchkrämpfe.
Das Nottelefon
muss für einmal warten.
Es klingelt immer
im falschen Moment.
Du bist eine ganz Liebe,
meine Gute, eine ganz Liebe.
Es ist fast vorbei, versprochen.
Voilà.
Es sollte gleich etwas besser sein.
Dass sie sich am Boden wälzt,
bedeutet leider ...
... dass es ihr gar nicht gut geht.
Romana bleibt isoliert
von den anderen Eseln.
Eléonore glaubt sowieso nicht,
dass sie von ihnen verletzt wurde.
Das kommt vom Wälzen.
Sie hat sich hin- und hergeworfen
und sich dabei
Fell und Haut aufgerissen.
Ich rufe Ihnen später an
wegen der Resultate der Blutprobe.
Nach ein paar Minuten geht es
Romana besser und sie steht auf.
Daniel ist erleichtert
und kann es nicht lassen,
einen kleinen Esel-Vortrag zu halten.
Esel sind extrem intelligent
und überhaupt nicht stur.
Nicht stur?- Nein,
man muss ihnen einfach Zeit lassen.
Sie müssen erst überlegen,
bevor sie etwas tun.
Darum sind sie eben intelligent.
Sie denken, bevor sie handeln.
Bevor sie etwas unternehmen,
analysieren sie die Situation.
Sie führen nicht blind
irgendwelche Befehle aus.
Deshalb ist es ein Kompliment,
wenn mich jemand Esel nennt.
Merci vielmals. Ade.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Im Kanton Waadt fährt Florence
zur Zwergziege Merlin.
Die Besitzerin hat am Körper
Rötungen festgestellt
und Angst,
es könnte eine Infektion sein.
Florence
möchte die Ziege untersuchen.
Aber zuerst muss man sie fangen.
* Leichte, verspielte Klänge *
Also, komm!
Ja, also ... uh ...
Dann schauen wir mal.
Kratzt sie sich sonst nirgends?
Unter dem Bauch
und manchmal am Zaun.
Aber das tun alle Ziegen.
Und schon ist klar, was los ist.
Hier sieht man es gut.
Sehen Sie die Viecher?
Es wimmelt ja nur so davon.
Merlin ist voller Läuse.
Sicher sind auch
die anderen zwei Ziegen befallen.
Wir müssen alle drei behandeln.
Ich hole das Medikament.
Und ich muss sie festhalten.
Kommen Sie bald wieder!
Aber dann klingelt das Telefon.
Es geht um eine Kuh,
die gerade kalbt.
Ist das Fruchtwasser
schon abgegangen?
Sie hat das Wasser
schon vor über 1 Std. verloren.
Gut, ich komme vorbei.
Das ist ein Notfall:
Florence darf keine Zeit verlieren
und muss die drei Ziegen
so schnell wie möglich behandeln.
Also, es gibt
eine kleine Spritze in den Hals.
Einmal ...
Hey!
... zweimal ...
So, das wäre geschafft.
Aber die dritte Ziege
möchte sich nicht stechen lassen.
Florence ist unter Zeitdruck und
hat keine Zeit, Fangen zu spielen.
Da braucht es Hilfe
vom Schwiegervater.
Er soll die Ziege einfangen.
* Florence lacht. *
Jetzt gehen sie rein.
Hopp, schnell!
Jetzt hat es geklappt.
* Lautes Meckern *
Stell dich nicht so an!
Voilà.
Ohne Läuse geht es dir viel besser.
So, das war's. Gut.
Also ... Ade.
Einen guten Nachmittag.
Ade. Danke vielmals.
Jetzt muss sie sofort weiter:
Eine Kuh braucht sie dringend -
in Morens im Kanton Freiburg.
Landwirt Gérald macht sich Sorgen,
weil seine Kuh Kamasutra
ihr Kalb nicht auf die Welt bringt.
Es ist nicht ihre erste Geburt,
aber diesmal
läuft gar nichts nach Plan.
Florence weiss: Wenn ein Bauer
sie anruft, ist es meistens schlimm.
Jede Geburt ist anders,
die Situation unvorhersehbar.
Man muss immer wieder
neue Lösungen finden.
Alle Szenarien sind denkbar.
Florence kann auf Gérald zählen.
Ein bisschen Wasser ...
- Da ist schon Wasser.
Na gut, dann gehen wir.
Der Bauer hat Erfahrung
mit der Geburt von Kälbern.
Ich habe mit der Hand
die Position überprüft.
Ich spürte die beiden Läufe
und den Kopf.
Es schien etwas schief zu liegen,
aber okay zu sein.
Nach dem Melken und dem Mittagessen
waren schon über 2 Std. vorbei.
Da wusste ich,
dass ich anrufen muss.
* Spannende Musik *
Hatte sie schon ihre Wehen?
Keine Wehen - eben nicht.
Darum ist Gérald beunruhigt.
Wenn eine Kuh nicht presst,
gibt es meistens Komplikationen.
Bleib ruhig!
Aber auch in Krisensituationen ist
Gérald nie um einen Witz verlegen.
Ein Kälbchen, nicht wahr?
Ein Kälbchen, ja.
Hm.
Könnte man nicht ...
- Es liegt falsch.
Liegt es verkehrt?
Es lag auf der Seite
und nicht gerade.
Darum konnte es die Kuh
nicht herauspressen.
Wenn es nicht gerade liegt,
hat die Mutter keine Wehen
und bringt es nicht alleine raus.
Wenn man nichts unternimmt,
könnten Kalb und Mutter sterben.
Florence
hat aber ein kleines Problem.
Ich bräuchte ...
- Ein Seil? Einen Faden?
Nein, etwas,
damit ich etwas höher bin.
Soll ich dich hochheben?
Zum Draufstehen?
- Und einen Kessel.
Dank dieser kleinen Hilfe
komm sie jetzt richtig gut ran.
Hinter seinem Humor steckt
eine grosse Erwartung an Florence.
Sie hat das Schicksal seines Kalbs
in ihren Händen.
Kann ich dir beim Umdrehen helfen?
- Nein, jetzt legt sie sich hin.
Mit einem Griff
hat sie das Kalb umgedreht.
Ging es deshalb nicht vorwärts?
- Nein, es lag nicht gerade.
Gérald ist erleichtert.
Heilanddonner!
Sie sind kompliziert, nicht?
Auf die Welt zu kommen,
ist eine Kunst.
Der erste Fehler, den wir machen,
ist, auf die Welt zu kommen.
Er ist
ein sehr sympathischer Klient.
Man fühlt sich immer wohl mit ihm.
Er ist nie gestresst,
egal, was passiert.
Die erste Hürde ist geschafft.
Aber jetzt muss das Kalb
noch aus dem Bauch rauskommen.
Keine einfache Sache, weil Kamasutra
immer noch nicht pressen will.
Komm schon, press!
Florence und Gérald
können Kamasutra noch so gut zureden,
das Kälbchen rührt sich nicht.
Ich versuche, den Kanal
mit den Händen freizulegen,
damit die Kuh
keine inneren Verletzungen erleidet.
Es sollte möglichst schnell gehen,
damit das Kalb lebendig
auf die Welt kommen kann.
Ein Kalb auf die Welt zu bringen,
wenn die Mutter nicht presst,
ist die reinste Tour de Force.
Nochmals pressen und dann ziehen,
ziehen, ziehen, ziehen, ziehen ...
Nicht loslassen.
Und noch einmal pressen.
Florence und Gérald
ziehen mit aller Kraft.
* Spannende Musik *
Nimm beide.
Das Kalb bleibt stecken,
weil es besonders gross ist.
Kamasutra kann fast nicht mehr.
* Muhen *
Aber dann  ... endlich.
Ich wollte das Kalb halten,
damit es nicht zu Boden fällt.
Dabei fielen wir beide zu Boden.
Das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Zum Glück ist nichts gebrochen,
und die Mutter
will sofort ihr Kleines sehen.
Es ist wunderschön.
- Hey, hey!
Voilà. Ja.
Hast du die Ketten
schon zurückgebracht?- Noch nicht.
Wo sind sie denn?
- Dort hinten.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Es ist schön, ein lebendiges Kalb
zur Welt zu bringen. Wunderbar.
Nicht immer sind sie lebendig.
- Ja, das kommt vor.
Gérald ist froh: Für einen Züchter
ist jede gelungene Geburt ein Erfolg
und stärkt
das Gleichgewicht des Hofes.
Es ist schon so im Dorf:
Ich bin der letzte Bauer mit Kühen.
Ein anderer hat noch Schweine.
Alle anderen haben aufgegeben.
Es ist ein harter Beruf:
Nie hat man Ferien.
Da ist jede gute Nachricht
besonders willkommen.
Florence muss weiter:
Es warten noch andere Tiere auf sie.
Im Tierspital in Bern
hat Alix ein Gespräch mit Laurence.
Ihr sieben Monate alte Katze Yuzu
wurde von zwei Hunden gebissen.
Es droht eine Lähmung
wegen eines Wirbelsäulenbruchs.
Also ja, sicher.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Wir haben uns für eine
konservative Behandlung entschieden.
Wir machen keine Operation
zur Stabilisation.
Darum bleibt Ihre Katze
noch ein Weilchen bei uns.
Jede Bewegung ist heikel wegen
der Wirbelsäule und es könnte ...
... schlimmer werden.
- Genau.
Darum sollte sie
noch eine Weile hierbleiben.
Es geht gut, sie ist super lieb.
- Ja, sie ist sehr süss.
Eine Operation ist nicht geplant.
Aber vielleicht operieren wir
morgen oder übermorgen.
Eigentlich müsste der Hundebesitzer
für den Spitalaufenthalt aufkommen.
Aber es waren streunende Hunde.
Haben Sie herausgefunden,
wem die Hunde gehören?
Wir haben sie gefunden
und identifiziert.
Es sind französische Hunde.
Auch ihre Besitzer sind Franzosen.
Sie sind wegen der Weinlese hier.
Okay.
Die Frage ist,
ob sie überhaupt zahlen können.
Sie haben im Gegensatz zu uns
keine Haftpflichtversicherung.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wenn man weiss,
wie diese Hunde leben ...
Als ich Anzeige erstattete,
erfuhr ich,
dass sie auch schon
Schafe gerissen haben.
Die Besitzer gehen arbeiten
und lassen ihre Hunde
auf der Strasse herumstreunen.
Das macht mich wirklich wütend.
Es hätte auch ein Kind
angegriffen werden können.
Also ...
Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Das Schlimmste ist vorbei.
Die Neuigkeiten von Alix
tun Laurence gut.
Seit gestern
hat sie einiges durchgemacht.
Kommen Sie gut nach Hause.
Gestern war es schlimm,
weil ich dachte, sie könne
die Hinterbeine nicht mehr bewegen.
Jetzt gibt es
vorerst keine Operation,
und die Wirbelsäule
wird stabilisiert.
Ich bin positiv überrascht
und erleichtert,
dass es unserer Katze
wieder etwas besser geht.
Yuzu wird weiter untersucht.
Es wird abgeklärt,
ob die Bauchwand durchgebissen wurde.
Hundezähne sind voller Bakterien.
Sollte der Bauchraum infiziert sein,
würde das die Katze nicht überleben.
* Zarte Klänge *
Weil die Wirbelsäule
noch immer sehr instabil ist,
nimmt sich Alix Zeit,
um Yuzu zu beruhigen.
Sie schnurrt,
aber nicht, weil sie zufrieden ist.
Ja, sie ist sehr gestresst,
die Pupillen sind weit offen.
Sie zittert auch ein wenig,
obwohl sie keine Schmerzen hat.
Das ist ein Riesenstress.
Na du?
Un grand stress.
Wir müssen darauf achten,
dass sie sich entspannt.
Denn ruckartige Bewegungen
sind sehr schlecht für den Rücken.
Nicht wahr, Yuzu?
Jetzt wird Yuzu nochmals geröntgt.
Wir wissen nicht,
was der Tierarzt gemacht hat,
ob die Hundebisse durch
die Bauchwand gehen oder nicht.
Man erkennt nicht, ob die Hundezähne
die Bauchwand perforiert haben.
Darum gibt es jetzt
auch noch einen Ultraschall.
Das Kätzchen
hat sich schon an Alix gewöhnt,
die sie keine Minute alleine lässt.
Das sieht subkutan aus.
Die Hundezähne drangen
also doch durch die Bauchwand.
Jetzt muss Yuzu
sofort in die Chirurgie.
Die Katze kommt sofort in den OP.
Frau Dr. Vincenti kommt sofort:
Jetzt muss es schnell gehen.
* Dramatische Musik *
Der Hundebiss im Bauch
bringt Yuzu in Lebensgefahr.
Hundebisse können eine sehr schlimme
Infektion im Bauch verursachen.
Die Infektion kann natürlich
auch die Organe betreffen.
Die Katze
kann wirklich sehr krank werden
und im schlimmsten Fall
auch daran sterben.
Die Operation dauert 1 Std.
Sie untersuchen das Bauchinnere,
reinigen es
und nähen es wieder sauber zu.
Nebst dem zugenähten Biss
entdeckten sie zwei weitere Wunden
in der Bauchwand,
aber zum Glück
ist kein Organ verletzt.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Yuzu kommt in die Überwachungspflege,
wo Alix
schon ungeduldig auf sie wartet.
Drainage.
- Mhm.
Hauptdrainage,
sonst ist alles stabil.
Okay, super. Vielen Dank.
Die Operation
hat Yuzu ziemlich mitgenommen.
Später schaut Alix nochmals vorbei,
wie es ihr geht.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Okay.
In Estavayer-le-Lac ruft Eléonore
den Besitzer von Romana an,
dem Esel, der sich am Boden wälzt.
Guten Tag. Hier ist Eléonore
von der Tierpraxis.
Guten Tag.
Ich rufe wegen Romana an.
Mit dem Resultat der Blutprobe lässt
sich ihr Zustand nicht erklären.
Das Blutbild ist normal,
aber Daniel ist sehr beunruhigt.
Romana wirft sich
noch immer ständig zu Boden
und wälzt sich hin und her.
Wenn Sie ganz sicher sein wollen,
müssen das Spezialisten anschauen.
Romana muss notfallmässig ins
Tierspital in Bern, aber das kostet.
Will Daniel seine Ersparnisse
für einen 25-jährigen Esel opfern?
Das Tier ist uns ans Herz gewachsen.
Ein Esel kann
zwischen 20 und 40 Jahre alt werden.
Sie kann noch
selbstständig aufstehen und gehen.
Das ist für mich entscheidend.
Solange sie das noch kann,
ist es vielleicht
doch nicht so schlimm.
Wenn er meint,
sie habe noch eine Chance,
dann rate ich ihm dazu, denn das
gehört auch zu unseren Aufgaben.
Wir wollen Leben erhalten,
nicht abkürzen.
Umso schöner ist es,
wenn die Leute motiviert sind.
Eléonore ruft im Tierspital an.
Könnte ich den zuständigen ...
Sie erklärt den Fall
dem Arzt in Bern.
Währenddessen
laden Daniel und sein Angestellter
Romana in den Anhänger.
Ein Transport in diesem Zustand
ist nicht schön.
Für mich ist wichtig,
dass ein Tier nicht leiden muss.
Natürlich stellt sich für mich bei
einem solchen Transport die Frage,
ob man ihr noch helfen kann
oder ob sie hinten im Anhänger nur
noch mehr Stress und Schmerzen hat.
Ist diese Fahrt
vielleicht doch zu viel für Romana?
Sie wälzt sich am Boden
und steht dann wieder auf.
Nein, sie hat kein Fieber.
Ja, es könnte eine Kolik sein.
Sie ist 25.
Der Blutzuckerspiegel ist hoch,
und sie ist ziemlich klein.
Bisher gab ich ihr
Menalgin und Flunixin.
Um 18 Uhr ist Daniel in der
Pferdeklinik des Tierspitals Bern.
Noch ein kurzer Blick,
wie es Romana geht.
Salut, Romana.
Sie hat die Reise überstanden.
Zum Glück geht es ihr gut.
Letztlich.
Guten Tag.
Nicole Ledermann.
- Daniel Würgler.
Sie sind mit dem Esel da?
- Mit der Eselin, Romana.
Wunderbar.
Sie können sie schon mal anmelden.
In der Zwischenzeit
laden wir den Esel ab.
Bei der Rezeption?
- Genau.
Während ich Romana anmeldete,
führte die Tierärztin im Anhänger
erste Untersuchungen durch.
Es ging alles sehr schnell.
Ich war überrascht,
dass es fast schneller
als bei Menschen ging.
Hat sie das zu Hause
auch schon gemacht?
Schon nach dem Abhören
haben die Tierärzte grosse Bedenken.
Romana schlägt aufgrund der Schmerzen
gegen die Wand des Anhängers.
Sie braucht sofort ein Schmerzmittel.
Daniel eilt zu seiner Eselin.
Ich habe sie soeben sediert.
Sie kann jetzt unmöglich aufstehen.
Der Blutkreislauf
ist momentan unglaublich schlecht.
Man muss Romana schnell ausladen,
es geht ihr immer schlechter.
Im Bauchraum
hat sich Flüssigkeit angesammelt.
Gut.
Im Tierspital wird als Erstes
ein Ultraschall gemacht,
um zu schauen,
wie es im Bauch aussieht.
In diesem Fall
stellte man leider fest,
dass die Situation hoffnungslos ist.
Da kann man nichts mehr machen.
Daniel muss seine Zustimmung geben,
um Romana
von ihren Schmerzen zu befreien.
Sie ist hier in guten Händen -
das weiss er.
Die Tiere werden hier von allen
mit Respekt behandelt.
Das ist für mich entscheidend.
Bis zur letzten Minute sollte
das Tier unsere Achtung spüren.
Bis zur letzten Minute
war Daniel bei seiner Eselin
und konnte sich
von ihr verabschieden.
Ich wünschte ihr alles Gute
und bedankte mich bei ihr
für die gemeinsame Zeit.
Wir haben
alles Menschenmögliche getan.
Wir haben nicht aufgegeben,
sie zum Spezialisten gebracht,
der sie sofort operiert hätte.
Man hat stets das Gefühl,
man habe versagt, das stimmt.
Aber zumindest
müssen wir nichts bereuen.
Daniel hat getan, was er konnte.
Als Landwirt hat er immer wieder
mit Leben und Tod zu tun.
Trotzdem schmerzt es immer,
wenn man sich von einem Tier
verabschieden muss.
Ich glaube,
man gewöhnt sich nie daran,
wenn man sich
von einem Lebewesen trennen muss.
Man braucht Zeit, um zu verdauen,
dass man ein geliebtes Wesen
verloren hat.
Mit jedem Tier
hat man eine andere Beziehung.
Wahrscheinlich müssen wir lernen,
dass auch das zum Leben gehört.
Es ist 8 Uhr.
Im Tierspital in Bern
dreht Alix ihre Patientenrunde.
Iss ein wenig!
Ich komme jeden Tag vorbei,
am Morgen und am Abend.
Ich streichle sie,
schaue, wie es ihnen geht.
Ich tue das nicht
aus medizinischen Gründen,
sondern eher aus Freundschaft.
Yuzu ist ihr
besonders ans Herz gewachsen.
Die anhängliche Katze wurde
von streunenden Hunden angegriffen.
Jetzt darf sie wieder nach Hause -
nach ein paar
letzten Streicheleinheiten.
Ich glaube,
alle in diesem Beruf lieben Tiere.
Nur sehen wir sie leider v.a. dann,
wenn es ihnen nicht gut geht.
Deshalb müssen wir
die Momente geniessen,
in denen es ihnen etwas besser geht.
Es ist oft frustrierend, das ist so.
Aber solche Momente
sind motivierend.
Die Katze fehlt mir jetzt schon,
denn ich habe sie oft besucht.
Ich weiss,
sie kann nicht im Spital bleiben.
Bei ihrer Familie
fühlt sie sich viel besser.
Auf dem Spitalparkplatz
kommt uns eine strahlende
Katzenbesitzerin entgegen.
Ihre Katze hatte einen Wirbel-
säulenbruch und tiefe Bisswunden.
Nach einer Operation
und fünf Tagen im Spital
kann sie ihre Yuzu
endlich wieder nach Hause nehmen.
Ich bin überglücklich.
Es ist eine grosse Erleichterung.
Ich bin wahnsinnig froh -
und glücklich.
Hey.
Ah, sie schnurrt.
Ein Problem bleibt noch:
Laurence weiss immer noch nicht,
ob die Hundebesitzer
für die Spitalkosten aufkommen.
Ich und meine Tochter haben uns
erkundigt und herausgefunden,
wem diese Hunde wirklich gehören.
Leider waren diese Personen
gerade im Begriff,
nach Italien zu reisen.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen,
wie es weitergeht.
Ich hoffe,
sie übernehmen die Rechnung.
Aber eben: Sie sind abgereist.
Seit zwei Tagen bekomme ich
keine Antwort mehr auf meine SMS.
Deshalb habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Alix gibt noch letzte Instruktionen,
wie es mit der Behandlung weitergeht.
Man muss sie wegen der Wirbelsäule
acht Wochen noch sehr ruhig halten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Acht Wochen lang kann sich die Katze
nur in einem kleinen Käfig bewegen.
Drei Schritte bis zum Futter,
drei Schritte bis zum Klo,
viele Streicheleinheiten.
Es ist zum Glück temporär, absehbar,
aber natürlich mühsam für Katzen,
die oft draussen sind.
Sie können Sie jetzt mitnehmen.
Sie ist so anhänglich.
Es ist Zeit, sich zu verabschieden.
Dann geben Sie Bescheid?
- Sicher. Vielen Dank.
Tschau, liebe Yuzu.
Es ist schön, wenn sie
nach Hause gehen können, aber ...
Klar, man hängt an ihnen.
- V.a. wenn sie so süss sind.
Gute Heimreise und rufen Sie an,
wenn etwas ist.
Ade.
- Merci vielmals.
Genau darum
habe ich diesen Beruf gewählt.
Für solche Patienten geht man
jeden Morgen gerne arbeiten.
Natürlich ist man nicht mit allen
so freundschaftlich verbunden.
Aber wenn ein Tier uns gegenüber
eine gewisse Zuneigung zeigt,
wird einem warm ums Herz.
Nach acht Wochen
meldet sich Laurence wie versprochen.
Yuzu hat sich bestens erholt.
Die Hundebesitzer
liessen nicht mehr von sich hören.
Laurence musste die Rechnung
von 2'000 Fr. selbst bezahlen.
Florence
ist erneut unterwegs zu Gérald.
Gestern brachte seine Kuh Kamasutra
ein Kalb zur Welt,
das bereits gesund
in seiner Box steht.
Sorgen bereitet ihm heute
die Mutterkuh.
Er hat das Gefühl, sie habe Fieber.
Salut.
- Hallo, wie geht's?
Kamasutra geht in ihrer Box
unruhig auf und ab.
Binden wir sie dort fest?
Oh!
Trennt man eine Kuh von ihrem Jungen,
kann sie recht aggressiv werden.
39,6 °C.
Ich gebe ihr Entzündungshemmer.
39,6 °C ist etwas höher als normal.
Die Körpertemperatur einer Kuh
ist normalerweise bei 38,5 °C.
Gérald hatte also recht.
Aber woher das Fieber kommt,
muss Florence erst herausfinden.
Hast du sie heute Morgen gemolken?
- Ja.
Gab sie Milch?
3-4 l, gestern auch.
Ich habe sie nicht ganz gemolken.
Das sind wichtige Informationen,
um eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Gérald hat einen Verdacht.
Vielleicht hat sie
den Mutterkuchen nicht abgestossen.
Gérald denkt, seine Kuh
sei vielleicht noch nicht sauber.
Nach der Geburt hätte sie
den Mutterkuchen abstossen sollen.
Gérald hat ihn überall gesucht,
aber nicht gefunden.
12-24 Std. nach der Geburt
muss die Hülle, in der das Kalb war,
ausgeschieden werden.
Wenn die Nachgeburt nicht abgeht,
droht eine Gebärmutterinfektion
mit Fieber
oder anderen Komplikationen
wie eine Labmagenverlagerung
oder eine Blutvergiftung.
Das ist ja gut und recht, aber ...
Einen Moment.
Ja, sie ist sauber.
Sauber? Dann hat sie ihn gefressen.
- Sie hat ihn gefressen.
Der Mutterkuchen
ist also doch abgegangen,
aber nicht lange im Stroh
liegen geblieben.
Manchmal frisst das Muttertier
seine Nachgeburt,
nachdem sie abgestossen wurde.
Darum weiss der Züchter
manchmal nicht,
ob die Kuh wirklich sauber ist.
Ganz ruhig.
Kann ich herauskommen?
Also.
Liegt es nicht an der Gebärmutter,
könnten die Zitzen entzündet sein.
Eine akute Mastitis
tritt oft nach dem Kalben auf.
Darum möchte Florence
die Zitzen kontrollieren,
aber Kamasutra sträubt sich dagegen.
Whoa! Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Ruhig bleiben! Gestern war sie
sanfter, sie ist wirklich nervös.
Ich hole den Absauger.
Florence braucht etwas Milch
wegen eines möglichen Infekts.
Gérald macht sich Sorgen.
Ist alles okay? Was denkst du?
Das gefällt mir nicht. Gar nicht.
Fieber bedeutet meist,
dass eine Infektion vorliegt.
Manchmal ist die Leber beschädigt.
Dann muss man sie
kurz nach dem Kalbern töten.
Das klingt nicht gut.
Wir müssen sie kürzer festbinden,
sonst wird sie ...
Florence traut Kamasutra nicht.
Sie ist viel zu unruhig,
ein Unfall jederzeit möglich.
Hey, hey!
- Hey!
Ich bin unruhige Tiere gewohnt.
Aber es ist wichtig,
dass sie gut festgebunden werden,
damit mir und auch dem Tier
nichts passieren kann.
Sie sollten mit einem Halfter
möglichst kurz festgebunden sein.
Wenn sie sich
nur wenig bewegen können,
können wir besser arbeiten.
Ist gut?
- Ja.
Trotzdem hat Florence Mühe,
Milch zu entnehmen.
Vorsicht.
Ein paar Sekunden -
und schon ist es vorbei.
Hast du sie?
- Ja, ist okay.
Mehr brauche ich nicht. Tipptopp.
Und das Ergebnis?
Aber es war nicht einfach.
Es ist leicht positiv.
Das ist normal nach dem Kalben.
Ja, das ist so.
- Sie hat keine Mastitis.
Ich höre sie nochmals ab.
Keine akute Mastitis, das Fieber
ist nicht die Folge einer Infektion.
Hör auf! Ja, komm.
Das Fieber ist nicht hoch.
Es kommt wohl von ihrer Nervosität.
Ist ein Tier unruhig,
steigt die Temperatur.
Ich fand keine Infektionen.
Darum spritzte ich ihr
ein entzündungshemmendes Mittel.
Das hilft auch gegen Schmerzen.
Sie hatte gestern
eine relativ schwere Geburt.
Das wir ihr guttun.
Also, ist gut?
- Ja, probieren wir es.
Stich mir einfach nicht ins Bein.
Gérald ist beruhigt
und wieder zu Scherzen aufgelegt.
Das tut ja gar nicht weh.
Ich spüre nichts.
Ja, also.- Sehr gut.
- Das war's.
Das Fieber kommt also
von der schwierigen Geburt
und der Trennung
von ihrem Neugeborenen.
Misst du nochmals Fieber?
Melde dich, wenn etwas ist.
Wenn sie morgen noch Fieber hat, ja.
Aber ich glaube, es sollte sinken.
Kamasutra geht es
dank der Medikamente bald besser.
Es ist 19 Uhr,
und Florence hat endlich Feierabend.
Der Arbeitsrhythmus
ist ziemlich schwierig.
Manchmal arbeitet man
mehrere Tage in Folge
und hat dazwischen
auch noch Nachtschicht.
Da ist sehr intensiv,
und es bleibt keine Freizeit,
um Sport zu treiben
oder ein Hobby zu pflegen.
Aber ich bin sehr glücklich,
wenn ich mit Tieren zu tun habe.
Das Leben eines Tierarztes
folgt dem Rhythmus der Natur
und ist geprägt
von Geburt, Tod und Krankheit.
Ein Leben mit intensivem Kontakt
zu Menschen und Tieren.
Ein Leben,
das man aus Leidenschaft wählt.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
Und nächste Woche:
Komm, Jessie!
Eléonore findet heraus,
wieso der Beagle
ein Problem an seinem Hintern hat.
Sie rutschte auf ihrem Hintern.
Das fand ich seltsam.
Das Problem ist banal,
aber sehr schmerzhaft.
Ich entdeckte ein Loch,
wo keines sein sollte.
Jessie muss operiert werden.
Im Tierspital Bern wird ein kleiner
Rassehund namens Diva eingeliefert.
Besitzerin Karina hängt sehr an Diva.
Alles dreht sich um sie.
Sie ist mein Leben.
Sie befürchtet,
Diva könnte schwer krank sein.
Das ist kein gutes Zeichen.
Und Florence
operiert Djamila im Stall.
Die Kuh hat ein Magenproblem,
das nur so behandelt werden kann.
Leg dich jetzt bitte nicht hin.
Djamila spürt nichts.
Und doch muss der Eingriff
sehr präzis sein.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020